J'ai écrit ce poème après avoir entendu une actrice très connue
dire à un journaliste très connu à la télévision,
« Je me suis mis à l'Internet,
j'aurais tellement préféré que ça soit mieux organisé. »
(Rires).
Si moi, je contrôlais Internet,
vous pourriez mettre aux enchères votre cœur brisé sur eBay,
avec l'argent gagné, aller sur Amazon,
acheter l'annuaire d'un pays où vous n'êtes jamais allé, appeler jusqu'à trouver
quelqu'un qui drague vraiment bien dans une langue étrangère.
(Rires).
Si j'étais chargé d'Internet,
vous pourriez chercher vos humeurs amoureuses sur Mappy,
prenez à gauche si grincheux, à droite si préoccupé, demi-tour en cas de « je te parle plus »,
avant de revenir sur baisers langoureux et amour sincère,
vous pourriez naviguez et comprendre chaque intersection d'émotions.
Parfois, je suis aussi superficiel qu'un moule à gaufre, mais je m'étends sur des kilomètres de toute part.
Si je possédais Internet, Napster, Monster et Friendster.com
ne serait qu'un seul site web, où vous pourriez écouter de la musique
tout en cherchant du boulot alors que vous discutez avec vos potes.
(Rires).
Si je dirigeais Internet, vous pourriez envoyer des mails aux morts.
Ils ne répondraient pas.
(Rires).
Mais vous auriez une réponse automatique. (Rires).
Leur nom dans votre boîte aux lettres. (Rires).
C’est tout ce qui compte.
Accompagné d'un message, « Hé, c'est moi. Tu me manques.
(Rires).
Tu verras, être mort c'est épatant ! En attendant,
retourne élever tes enfants, répands la paix, et mange des bonbons. »
Si j'avais à concevoir l'Internet, enfance.com passerait en boucle
un enfant dans un verger, un bâton de ski en guise d'épée,
un couvercle de poubelle en guise de bouclier, hurlant
« Je suis l'empereur des oranges. Je suis l'empereur des oranges. »
Vous me suivez ? (Rires).
GrandMere.com : recettes à biscuits et à toilette de chat.
Un, deux, trois.
Ce qui nous amène sur cestbath.com C'est mon grand-père.
Direction exflicbourruapresquatre_marriages.papa qui vous ramène sur
etourdiemaispenseaupaindepicepour_Noel.maman qui télécharge le garçon du verger, l'empereur des oranges,
qui grandit pour finir comme moi, le gars qui va toujours un peu trop loin.
Si j'étais l'empereur d'Internet,
j'imagine que je serais toujours un mortel, non ?
Mais quand j’en serais là, j'aurais probablement déjà le moins cher des crédits
et le plus agrandi des pénis.
(Rires).
Et je bannirais le spam dès le premier jour. Je n’en aurais pas besoin.
Je serais une sorte de génie de l'Internet, mais moi j'aimerais passer à la version au-dessus, devenir Dieu, et d'un coup
paf, passer sans fil.
(Rires).
Peut-être que Google m'engagerait.
J'irais zipper vos serveurs et firewalls comme un virus, jusqu'à ce que le World Wide Web soit aussi sage, sauvage et organisé
qu'un miracle oracle des temps modernes peut l'être, mais, ohhh,
tu verras comment je craque ton Mac,
ou dépèce ton PC, quand je planerais sur la sphère dieu.net.
J'imagine que c'est la vie.
La question n'est pas de savoir si tu peux. Mais, qu'est-ce tu fais ?
On peut interférer avec l'interface.
On peut faire du « Millionième visiteur » l'hymne du cyber-espace chaque fois qu'on se connecte au bon moment.
Vous ne prierez pas.
Vous n'écrirez pas de psaume.
Vous ne psalmodierez pas.
Vous ne ferez qu'envoyer un email béni à celui en qui vous croyez
à l'adresse : daladali@dalidada.com.
Merci à vous, TED. (Applaudissements).